spawn is fighting Batman
you heard that right ladies and
gentlemen now you are either going to
love this comic or you're going to hate
this comic but there is one thing I want
to establish beforehand so whenever it
comes to intercompany crossovers these
stories are designed to be read in
isolation technically speaking Batman
and spawn have crossed over a couple
other times before in fact it was two
times and they both happened in 1994.
this story came out last year at the
time they were recording this video in
2022 but it's basically written in a way
where these characters have never met
each other now the other thing is that
because it's basically out of continuity
you can't really bring anything going on
with spawn at the moment into the story
and you can't really bring anything
going on with Batman at the moment in
the story it's just kind of its own
thing but what this does here is this
initially picks up with this idea that
Wanda is effectively dead right now for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with that Wanda was at one point the
wife of Al Simmons before he basically
died and ended up becoming spawn once he
came back his spawned which was like
five years after he died he ended up
discovering that Wanda had married his
best friend Terry and then all the
continuity goes forward from there the
idea here though is that Wanda is
effectively dead and so what ended up
happening is that information was more
or less leaked to spawn that there is a
quote-unquote place he can go to or a
city he can go to where he can capture
what he needs in order to get his wife's
Soul Back which is basically the black
beast now for Batman things are
basically just traditionally Batman
right which is he is dealing with the
anniversary of the death of his parents
and the death of his mom largely weighs
on him and the death of his dad weighs
on him in the same way and he honors
their memory by running out in the
middle of the night and beating up
criminals what's different about this is
that as Batman is out patrolling and
doing his thing he suddenly set upon by
spawn and again because spawn was given
information and saying that like this
guy right this this black beast
basically has a kind of suit and the
ability to access a portal to
effectively hell that can bring your
wife's soul back this is the guy you
have to defeat the big kicker about all
this is that spawn
absolutely demolishes Batman and it's
not even close I mean it's not even a
close thing like it's not like Batman is
like on the ropes right and he's barely
holding his own right you know he's like
yeah I I can do it you know just put me
back in put me back in coach I I I can
take this guy no man I mean not even in
hell would you see a massacre like this
Batman's just getting straight up
thrashed and he does everything he can
he's like throwing batarangs his spawn
and spawns like blocking the batarangs
right just all kinds of stuff he's like
you have something that I need demon but
then this is where like the plot devices
come into play because what ends up
happening is that as these two are
fighting and Batman's getting absolutely
thrashed that spawn steps into what's
called a dead zone and a dead zone is
basically a place where his powers
effectively shut down and Al Simmons
just becomes like your average
run-of-the-mill human now of course
Batman ends up taking this opportunity
and absolutely smashing spawn right
beating the crap out out of Al Simmons
now before anybody comes along and says
see I told you Batman could defeat spawn
no he couldn't either it literally took
Todd Todd McFarland just creating an
arbitrary thing for Batman to be able to
defeat spawn under any normal
circumstance Batman has no chance I mean
let's just be honest with ourselves
right Batman is going to get demolished
by spawn and Al Simmons is going to be
home in time for cornflakes and that's
just the way that it is there's no
arguing that point but here's the funny
thing about this right because Batman as
he's like facing off against this guy
the whole thing is being watched by the
court of owls now for those of you guys
who are unfamiliar with this right one
this artwork is done by a guy named Greg
capullo when DC rebooted Batman in 2011
with the new 52 Greg capullo took over
the artwork for Batman and Scott Snyder
wrote Batman the first story arc they
had was the court of owls they were one
of the most interesting groups that had
really ever been created in the Batman
Mythos which after Scott Snyder left
Batman DC promptly ruined so the idea
behind the court of owls is that they
were literally just an organization a
criminal Enterprise that had operated
within Gotham City for hundreds of years
and even Batman thought they were a myth
he didn't believe they were actually
real until he discovered that they were
and that they were seemingly responsible
for the death of like Thomas and Martha
Wayne they had just kind of pulled all
these different strings behind the
scenes so it's one of those crazy
moments right now here the court of owls
is basically or seemed to be the ones
behind all of this that the court of
owls are finding a way to basically
destroy Batman and that they brought
spawn in to do that but even above the
court of owls is basically an
unidentified figure that effectively
told the court like we can grant you
powers that you just never would be able
to imagine having on your own but you
need to find a way to bring spawn in to
kill Batman that kind of a thing right
it's very Cloak and Dagger and very very
murky but focusing on the nature of this
whole conflict that initially spawn
tries to taunt Batman and actually like
bring him over or you know out of the
Dead Zone and simply saying like if you
truly believe you can defeat me right if
you really want to fight me then step
out of the Dead Zone and come fight me
directly but the response of Batman is
no right like the reality here is that
we're being watched right there is a guy
right there now of course by the time
spawn looks that guy's basically taking
off he sees just enough of him to know
that he was there and to know Batman was
telling the truth but the response is
that he says like you need like we need
to have a conversation now the other
part in which these guys are able to
find a sort of common ground is that on
the 26th it's basically when Wanda and
Martha both died is it a plot device
absolutely but it's what allows the
story to move forward and so even though
spawn seems to put off all these
trappings that like his desire is to
basically just destroy Batman because he
needs Batman's powers effectively in
order to open a portal and get his wife
sold back their spawn starts to realize
that one Batman seems to be telling the
truth and two that they really are both
being manipulated so where Batman steps
Out Of The Dead Zone and then steps up
to spawn spawn doesn't kill him and
instead the two of them end up traveling
back to the bat cave in order to have a
conversation with each other and what
they do is they actually kind of compare
notes and in a lot of ways it's Todd
McFarland sort of establishing that
these two characters are very very
similar for example Batman has his own
bat family right the different robins
and so on spawn basically has the same
thing the two of them run around in the
middle of the night and they beat up
criminals and so on and so forth now
it's not a direct comparison spawn has
fought God and Satan and different
things like that and the level of Power
with regards to the various beings in
his own universe or at least that he
faces off against in a lot of ways are
comparable to the various people that
Batman faces off against right Batman
does not routinely fight like Lucifer
Morningstar or any of those guys but you
do have the whole vertigo side John
Constantine zatana Trigon all those
different things and so it's really
really comes striking the similarities
these characters have more so than that
one of the things things that spawn says
is that this enemy that's operating
behind the scenes that you have to step
your game up because if you don't they
will inevitably win that sure you have
people like Superman or the person you
call the Man of Steel but at the end of
the day the kind of powers that are out
there and the kind of powers from where
I'm from who we're looking to take over
where you are right now they will
destroy him they will annihilate him not
in the sense that they will physically
kill him but in the sense that they will
corrupt him they will turn him into a
dark and twisted version of himself and
he even says that by literally showing
his true face which it's cool to see
that even after all these years spawn's
face is held together by literally a
shoestring but like he shows his true
face that like he is a demonic presence
and he's like this is what you will
become so in a lot of ways it's kind of
taking these two characters with these
diametrically opposing views right spawn
who believes in killing and doing
whatever he has to do in order to
achieve his goal and Batman with a stark
no killing rule I mean sure he may beat
you to the point that you are never able
to walk again you're drinking your food
through a straw and you have to
communicate with a computer because you
can't talk but at least you're not dead
so it's one of those things where it's
like Batman has his own his own own
rules and policies on how he does things
right you may be better off dead but at
least you're not right according to
Batman so it's one of those things where
it's kind of cool to see these sort of
uh opposing views but the reality is
that given everything that's going on
what they need is information what they
have to do is track down who it is that
is seemingly operating behind the scenes
so of course Batman has his method where
he just kind of roughs people up a
little bit and spawn has his message
where like he breaks their jaws rips
their throats open some guy's eye is
hanging out of his head about another
dude's face is torn off I mean it's fun
just being awesome you know what I mean
like just the most awesome stuff that
spawn does but the thing about this is
that their own investigations ultimately
lead them to the Joker which is awesome
because spawn meets the joker now here's
the funny thing about this right we
don't get a great big huge conflict or
any thing like that but it is cool the
way the Jokers Jokers really uh kind of
portrayed here one word has reached the
ears of Joker of Spawn now it is a
little finicky the way that is handled
by Todd McFarlane because it's one of
these things where the amount of
information Joker has about spawn and
the nature of Spawn seems to move Beyond
just word reaching his ears right like a
guy on the street tells his friend who
tells a guy in Arkham Asylum who tells
the Joker right it's it's beyond that
it's more like the Joker like like spawn
has been around for a very long time and
the Joker is well aware of who spawn is
but again that flies in the face of the
fact that spawns basically here for the
very first time so again it's somewhat
wonky but one of the things that goes on
here is that with their investigation
basically they've been informed that the
Joker is working alongside the court of
owls and the response to Joker is like
well they're all wrong he's like but I
forgive you he's like it doesn't mean
that we can't be friends though because
I hear you and I have a lot in common
and the Joker actually removes his face
and he shows spawn just how gruesome his
face looks now this was building off the
new 52 right for those of you guys who
are familiar with that the Joker did not
initially pop up in DC Comics he had
like a single appearance in Detective
Comics and then you didn't see him for a
number of years in DC but then he just
seemingly shows up out of nowhere but
what he had done is he had literally had
his face surgically removed and then he
just reattached it using what's
basically a kind of mask-like
contraption he treated his own his own
actual face as a mask you never really
saw what all the mess was under his face
when his face was removed so this is
like one of the first times that we
actually see it which is really really
cool but the reality here is that spawn
gets tired of just how insane The Joker
Is how goofy The Joker Is and so of
course spawn initially says like look
give us what it is that we want to know
otherwise I'm going to tear you apart
and Joker knowing enough about spawn to
know that spawn serious and with Batman
just not really seeming to jump in the
way like hey you know I mean it's a
joker I think gossip might be better off
without him then it leads to the Joker
jumping information and what he says is
you guys heard wrong what you guys heard
is Joker is working with the court of
owls what was actually said is Joe Kerr
is working with the court of owls a
wholly different person like Joseph Kerr
now the other part about this is that
when they take that information and they
effectively leave we get this bit of a
teaser well the reason why the Joker
seems to know so much about spawn is
because after they're gone he actually
ends up meeting with what's basically
these miniature clowns that look like
miniature versions of the Violator from
the spawn Mythos so seemingly the
Violator arguably the most dangerous foe
of Spawn and a character that was highly
modeled after the Joker would basically
be teaming up with the joker himself now
this is a One-Shot comic there's no
indication that there's ever going to be
another one of these again there might
be but DC and Todd McFarland and Gregor
pillow and them haven't announced one
but what it does is it transitions away
from Batman and spawn and it focuses on
the talent now for those of guys who are
unfamiliar with the Talon it goes hand
in hand with the court of of owls right
the town is basically the henchman right
he's the guy that just goes out and does
the dirty work for the court now because
the Talon is a person who is technically
dead but has been reinvigorated or at
least given some kind of essence that
kind of brings him back to life he has
like enhanced strength speed durability
things like that it makes the Talon
stronger than Batman but weaker than
Superman so he kind of falls into that
little bit of a gray area there but he's
a very dangerous foe because he's
exceedingly good at hand-to-hand combat
I would argue he's probably on par with
somebody like Deathstroke he's highly
capable right incredibly capable but
what he's looking for is basically one
of the pearls of Martha Wayne and the
reason why is that Martha at least in
this Pearl was basically a means by
which this portal could be opened that
would allow the forces of Hell from
spawn's reality to enter into the main
DC Universe and then seemingly operate
under the control of the court of owls
and as we know that wouldn't be the case
then of course these forces of Hell have
their own motivations on their own
schemes they would immediately take over
the court they would annihilate all of
them then they would probably conquer
the world and even spawn kind of sees
that's most likely the case but in the
midst of the talent meeting with Joseph
Kerr the current leader of the court of
owls that what it does is it leads to
spawn teleporting into the room
snatching up Joseph Kerr and then
telling Talon if you want him back come
and find us and he teleports away back
to Batman right kind of the the plan
that the two of them have created and so
following that with these two guys
working together what they do is they
arrive at Arkham Asylum and they
currently wait for the Talon to show up
now initially Batman sets on the Talon
but it's really more of a temporary
distraction than anything else because
as the two of them are fighting to a
degree spawn steps in and says let
Batman go right and then Batman runs off
to complete the other part of the plan
and that the Talon and spawn kind of
have an initial standoff now the Talon
seems to know about the nature of the
Dead zones that spawns Powers basically
disappear when he steps into a dead zone
and so tell him of course challenges
them come over here and face me if you
there but then spawn realizes what's
actually going on that the Talon is
after the Pearl and so the response is
if what you want is the Pearl which
Joker has right over here you're gonna
have to come to me and that you need to
fight me directly and so it's kind of a
cool little moment because at the end of
the day the talent literally jumps into
conflict with spawn now this is where
the whole idea of the Dead zones gets a
little murky that they feel like more of
a plot device than anything else because
the dead zones at least Arkham itself is
seemingly built on one of these dead
zones and that the idea behind this is
that with it nerfing or kind of reducing
and even removing the powers of Spawn it
does turn him into a normal human but
what you're actually going to see over
the course of the rest of this comic is
that the rules are arbitrary that what's
gonna happen is there's going to be
moments where spawn is basically in a
dead zone but he's still using his
powers right like it's just one of those
murky things Todd McFarland kind of has
a tendency to do that right just kind of
arbitrarily create rules in order to
tell a story but as the two of them are
fighting one of the things that's kind
of cool about this is the talent is for
the most part able to hold his own to a
degree now because they're fighting in a
dead zone and because of the fact that
it's just spawn without his traditional
Powers it's the only real reason that
Talon's able to stand a chance in the
first place because again Talent would
be torn apart by spawn under any normal
circumstance and so realizing that they
have basically moved their fight into a
dead zone and spawn's powers are
essentially gone the one ends up
happening is Talon actually gets rid of
his own weapons and says let's just have
a straight up knock down drag out fight
and so as the two of them are facing off
against each other it's bare knuckle
stuff now a lot of the value of this is
really predicated on whether or not you
care about talent in the first place if
you don't care about Talon this doesn't
really matter to you it's not really
relevant to you if you love the
character of talent right the 12 of you
out there who do then like it's a really
cool moment right I say 12 because no
one cares about the talent
but the thing about this though is that
Batman of course kind of hooking up this
sort of system right like working on his
own individual plan we didn't initially
know the full ramifications of it but
what ends up going on here is that Joe
Joseph Kerr basically picks up the arm
band of the Talon right which has a kind
of hidden dagger straight up Assassin's
Creed stuff level here and initially
tries to take out Batman when he arrives
back on the scene and even fires off a
couple of these things in order to try
to kill Batman and or spawn but that's
when spawn tells him take out the lights
right like take the lights down which
Batman successfully does and when that
happens spawn uses his powers to morph
into Batman and then basically impales
Joseph Kerr on the spot now the reason
why he does this and it's one of the
coolest things that's that's so
interesting the reason why he does this
is because not even Joseph Kerr knows
that it's spawn he thinks it's Batman
and so when the lights come back on the
various prison inmates cannot see the
actual Batman all they see is is
literally what looks looks like Batman
standing there with an impaled Joseph
Kerr on his arm now the reason why this
happened is because it was basically
spawn giving Batman a leg up right
giving Batman a chance to actually live
up to fear because one of the things to
know is that within the Batman Mythos
Batman doesn't kill and everybody knows
it right like every criminal out there
knows Batman does not kill it's the
thing he does not do and so it's the one
thing they don't have to be afraid of
Batman might beat the crap out of him he
might beat them within an inch of their
life but he won't take the extra step so
as long as they're willing to do what
Batman's not willing to do that in turn
they will always have the upper hand but
by now basically seeing this illusion
that Batman killed a guy now everybody
believes Batman is willing to kill if
they push him far enough and that's the
point that spawn makes right he says
like now they'll fear you right because
now they think if they push you too far
you might just kill them right like
that's the reality here and he says
they'll all think twice before coming
after you again and you just might
survive a little bit longer so it's kind
of a cool situation because in a lot of
ways it establishes this idea that Al
Simmons is more aware of the the issue
with Batman refusing to kill than Batman
is right for Bruce Wayne he sees it as
like a moral argument right a moral
thing it's a line he doesn't cross what
Al Simmons sees is what's on the other
side of that line what awaits Batman
because of his unwillingness to kill
that it will eventually catch up to him
in some form or fashion and he'll get
himself killed it's why I've always said
Batman's no kill rule is kind of a silly
thing now of course in the midst of all
this the Talon jumps back up again now
of course a lot of that's because of the
fact that the talent is highly capable
has a bit of a healing Factor different
things along those lines and of course
in the middle of this whole fight that
the Talon has Al Simmons who's back in
his human form because they're in a dead
zone he literally tells him use the
Pearl and open the portal or I'm going
to kill Al Simmons on the spot and the
response of Batman is an initially a
bluff where he says like I don't care
you just killed a man it doesn't matter
to me he's like but when you do I
release this button and this entire
Asylum shuts down every cell in here
will open you'll never take over Gotham
City do you know why it won't be
Superman or the flash who stops you
it'll be them the villains now the funny
thing about this is that on the surface
it seems like a ridiculous argument
right the enemy of my enemy is my friend
if the court of owls succeed in killing
Batman then the villains would be more
thankful than anything else like hey man
thanks a lot dude like we owe you one
buddy and they team up and they conquer
Gotham City and in fact that's what the
Talon believes right he says like what
about you they'll tear you apart and his
response is maybe but not at first right
Batman says they may hate me but there's
one thing they hate more that's anyone
who helped make me in this Grand fight
that you had with spawn and in this
fight that you had with me you literally
just told all these villains who were
watching that it was you that you were
the one along with the court of owls
that created me in the first place
they'll hunt you down and they'll do
what they like most and that's hurting
people you'll spend the next decade
fighting them and there's dozens of them
right you have two face you have the
Joker you got Killer Croc you got the
penguin with this crazy amazing
umbrellas you have all kinds of villains
here who know all the right people and
they know places that you can't get to
they'll work together they'll work
against you but you'll never take over
Gotham in one Fell Swoop and so the
response of the talent is your bluffing
and that's when Batman says then kill
Simmons if you think I'm bluffing then
kill him right and while you're at it
kill me too so I'll release this button
and every all these single Villas will
just come pouring out of their cells and
so that's what he says then who's gonna
save your mom's soul and that's what all
this was predicated on all of this was
predicated on the idea that word would
reach the ears of Batman that in using
this Pearl to open this portal he'd be
able to get his mother's Soul Back
specifically his mother I guess he
doesn't care about his father in this
story which is kind of a weird thing but
he'd be able to get his mother's soul
back but the reality here is that Batman
came to terms with the death of Martha
Wayne years ago if this whole scheme had
played out within like a year of him
becoming Batman right like Batman year
One then yeah definitely they would have
been like he would have just opened that
portal in a heartbeat because at that
point he was still dealing with the loss
of his parents and he was still trying
to figure out how to be Batman while
simultaneously respect their memory but
in truth he wanted them back basically
more than he ever did but at this point
in his life he's come to terms with
their deaths and in fact him coming to
terms with their deaths is manifested in
him going out and fighting crime in
their honor to try to make Gotham City a
better place in effect this whole plan
of the court of owls is a day late and a
dollar short and so literally he just
like kicks the Talon and the Pearl goes
flying because what happens is the
talent ends up in the arms of Spawn and
he just gets whisked away like literally
spawn just teleports away which was kind
of weird because they're in a dead zone
and that shouldn't necessarily be able
to happen but in the middle of all this
really is part of kind of an epilogue
here that what we get is a bit of a
teaser which is to say that the Violator
was seemingly behind all of this stuff
what the end goal is we don't entirely
know and again because this is a
One-Shot comic I'm not entirely sure
that we're ever going to find out but it
would be cool to see the Violator and
the Joker team up but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end thank you all for watching I
will catch you all later
peace